so you were talking about dirac
yes i was talking about direct right so
direct was trying to now combine this
schrodinger's equations which which was
described in the context of you know
trying to
talk about how these probabilistic waves
of electrons move for the atom which was
good for
for speeds which were not too close to
the speed of light to what happens when
you get to the near the speed of light
so then you need relativity so then
dirac tried to combine einstein's
relativity with quantum mechanics
so he tried to combine them and he wrote
this beautiful equation
the dirac equation which roughly
speaking
take the square root of of the
einstein's equation in order to connect
it to schrodinger's time evolution
operator which is
first order in time derivative to get
rid of the
the naive thing that einstein's equation
would have given which is second order
so you have to take a square root
now square root usually has a plus or
minus sign when you take it
and when he did this he originally
didn't notice this post didn't pay
attention to this plus or minus sign but
later physics pointed out to direct says
look there's also this minus sign
and if you use this minus sign you get
negative energy
in fact uh it was very very annoying
that you know somebody else tells you
this obvious mistake you make paulie
famous physicist told direct this is
nonsense you're going to get negative
energy with your equation which negative
energy without any bottom you can go all
the way down to negative
infinite energy so it doesn't make any
sense direct thought about it and then
he remembered paulie's
exclusion principle before just before
him paulie had said you know
there's this principle called the
exclusion principle that you know two or
two electrons cannot be on the same
orbit
and so direct said okay you know what
all these negative energy states
are filled orbits occupied
so according to you uh
uh mr paulie there's no place to go so
therefore they only have to go positive
sounded like a big cheat and then paulie
said oh you know what
we can change orbits from one order to
another what if i take one of these
negative energy orbs and put it up there
then it seems to be a new particle which
has opposite
properties to the electron it has
positive energy but it has positive
charge
what is that like
dirac was a bit worried he said maybe
that's proton because proton has plus
charge
he wasn't sure but then he said well
maybe it's proton but then they said no
no no it has the same mass as the
electron cannot be proton because proton
is heavier
the iraq was stuck he says well then
maybe another part we haven't seen
by that time direct himself was getting
a little bit
worried about his own equation and his
own crazy interpretation
yes until a few years later anderson in
photographic cosmic
in the photographic place that he had
gotten from this cosmic rays
he discovered a particle which goes in
the opposite direction that the electron
goes when there's a magnetic field
and with the same mass exactly
like what the iraq had predicted and
this was what we call now
positron and in fact beginning with the
work of direct we know that every
particle has an anti-particle
and so this idea that there's an
anti-particle came from this simple math
you know there's a plus and a minus
from the direct quote-unquote mistake
so again trying to combine ideas
sometimes the math is smarter than the
person who uses it to
apply it and we try to resist it and
then you you kind of confronted by
criticism which is the way it should be
so physicist comes and said no no that's
wrong and you correct it and so on so
that
is the development of the idea there's
particle there's anti-particle and so on
so this is the beginning of
development of quantum mechanics and the
connection with relativity
but the thing was more challenging
because we had to also describe how
electric and magnetic fields
work with quantum mechanics this was
much more complicated because it's not
just one point
electric and magnetic fields were
everywhere so you had to talk about
fluctuating and a fuzziness of
electrical field and magnetic fields
everywhere
and the math for that was was was very
difficult to deal with
and this led to a subject called quantum
field theory fields like electric and
magnetic fields had to be quantum
had to be described also in a wavy way
feinman
in particular was one of the uh pioneers
and
along with schwinger's and others to try
to come up with the formalism to deal
with
fields like electric and magnetic fields
interacting with electrons
in a consistent quantum fashion and they
developed this beautiful theory quantum
electrodynamics from that and
later on that same formalism quantum
field theory led to the
discovery of other forces and other
particles all consistent with the idea
of quantum
mechanics so that was how physics
progressed
and so basically we learned that all
particles and all the forces
are in some sense related to particle
exchanges
and so for example electromagnetic
forces are
are mediated by a particle we call
photon and
uh and so forth and same for other
forces that they discovered strong
forces and the weak forces so
so we got the sense of what quantum
field theory is is that a big leap
of uh of an idea that uh
particles or fluctuations in the field
like the idea that everything is a field
is the old einstein
light is a wave both a particle and a
wave kind of idea
is that a huge leap in our understanding
of conceiving the universe's fields i
would say so i would say that on
viewing the particles this duality that
bohr mentioned between particles and
waves that waves can behave sometimes
like particles sometimes like waves
is one of the biggest leaps of uh
imagination
that quantum mechanics made visits too
so i agree that that is
quite remarkable
you